voici les deux voitures qui font
particulièrement la fierté des salariés
au montage la 500.000e 3008 à droite et
la millionième 308 à gauche un événement
que psa a souhaité immortaliser de
voiture de l'année dans la même usine
aucun autre site de production
d'automobiles nasa en europe bravo à
tous merci à tous soyez fiers de votre
job la concrétise en fait finalement un
engagement projet une réussite au niveau
de la production et on est fiers
finalement de d'avoir fabriqué cette bio
nième 308 désormais 3008 est en tête de
son segment en europe devant le
volkswagen tiguan et le qashqai donc
pense que c'est une grande fierté pour
tous les salariés du site et pour
l'ensemble des fournisseurs de la
filière automobile en bourgogne france
comté
ces deux modèles essence font-ils partie
des derniers à être produits dans son
projet de loi dévoilé lundi la ministre
des transports elisabeth bornes dit
vouloir faciliter la transition des
parcs automobiles vers l'électrique ou
le biogaz à sochaux 50 % des véhicules
sont des diesels et les 50% restants des
essences pourtant psa n'a pas attendu le
projet de loi de la ministre pour
produire des voitures moins polluantes
le site de chooz se prépare à l'hybride
nous avons actuellement des prototypes
qui sont prêts nous lancerons l'année
prochaine des véhicules hybrides en 3008
les premiers travaux concernant l' usine
ont été faits en août dernier nous
produisons actuellement au ferrage des
caisses qui servent aux enfers de
l'hybride et les premières voitures de
série début 2000
19 seront produites à ce jour après la
commercialisation de la 3008 hybride
psa devrait produire des voitures
électriques